[Music]
third glass tonight put it on my tab you
drinking - remember forget giving a [ __ ]
won't get you a better tip can't help
how my whole family was killed in a car
accident
someone did horrific experiments on me
you know this super vigilante [ __ ] keeps
coming at me do you know Captain America
I want to absorb alias investigations
you don't want me you just want to
eliminate the competition
I never take no for an answer how rapey
of you something happened behind these
doors I have 17 years of questions and
they are deep just knowing what was done
to you might help you we were made here
me and something else the only way to
find it is to open the door wider
[Music]
the powers were side effect how many
others are there like me
let it go there is a killer you cannot
control I didn't ask for any of this
Jessica might not want a psychic but she
needs one you're not super time off keep
time who are you how dare you
[Music]
what if AC needs me worse what are you
gonna do I don't know depends on if I
can get through this night without
losing my [ __ ]
[Music]
it takes a monster
to stop a monster
what did they do to us like you to stay
mom keep you inside
[Music]